round six of the London chess classic of  the last stop on the grand chest tour we  Fabiano karana threatening to run away  with the title the rest of the field  came into the day desperate for a win  England's hope Michael Adams seemed to  have a puncher's chance against yonder  from the achi but the Russian star  managed to flip the script and score a  big win vaulting himself into clear  second place in the event Hikaru  Nakamura was on the verge of winning  against world champion Magnus Carlsen  but the tour leader dug in his heels  with a Titanic defense and saved the  game with a miracle draw of a heart to  choose what plan to go for especially as  many things let's look winning but it  simply chose the wrong plan and there  are only three rounds to go with all to  play for exciting round 7 action of the  season-ending classic coming up next  [Music]